c'est la question à laquelle la pièce de
théâtre j'habite sky apporte des
réponses une mise en scène avec cinq
habitants saint quentinois de comédiens
accompagne ses acteurs en herbe
il porte la parole de la population des
douze communes de l'agglomération
jerry kelly pr alors moi je vais parler
de mon appartement où j'ai habité en
premier à elancourt et qui était
vraiment un bâtiment peu ordinaire on va
dire où il y avait beaucoup de problèmes
donc voilà faut venir au spectacle pour
le voir vous pouvez l'entendre ce qui
est aussi important cette porte donc de
porter la parole des habitants des
personnes qui ont bien voulu témoigner
pour pouvoir dont vous présentez un peu
leur vie leur vécu au niveau de la vie
nouvelle
guyancourt toi ville prévient mme annie
quoi ou encore qu les siens ce spectacle
est une succession de scènes lecture de
témoignages des mouvements sur scène et
projections un projet construit en
partenariat avec le musée de la ville
mise en scène par catherine laine de la
compagnie 7 septembre j'ai recueilli des
témoignages au j'étais presque à 150
témoignages sur les douze communes j'ai
fait un gros travail dans les
associations
je suis allé à la rencontre des gens et
cetera et cetera
et ce spectacle donc parle de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des douze
communes et du lien qu'on peut créer
entre elles mais surtout de l'humain
surtout des habitants de ce qu'ils y
font ce qu'ils y rêve ce qu'il projette
dans leur vie la première représentation
le mercredi 7 juillet au théâtre
national avant une seconde prévue le
vendredi 9 juillet au scarabée de la
verrière pour découvrir les multiples
visages de saint quentin en yvelines
le coup de coeur nous étions tous
d'accord c'était la maison qu'il nous
fallait